this video was sponsored by le land Oh
hail to the great of famous author
planning that's right
there's me I'm back baby to play a video
game you guys thought I don't like games
what that's because I'm too good at it
y'all just Christ you should be thanking
me for not playing games because I
wrecked your answer I wrecked your mama
thing your daddy and now I'm gonna wreck
y'all in wormack ah oh you may be
familiar with this game before it has a
lot of similarity to all the games but
it has a lot of new features like
questions different ability this game of
three different skills boosters you can
play multiplayer with your friends
ratings meta game artifacts hell yeah
and the best part you can select custom
skins that's supposed to be me
hell yeah hey it's got the brofist
hahaha oh I don't I don't think this is
me but it's cute so I'm gonna go with it
I mean I'm the best goddamn game on
laughs I'm going to take over the planet
bro hell yeah so now I have this skill
which does what what it's to boost okay
cool and then later on I unlock new
skills we are going to number one is up
and until the POTUS past hospital boy
number one go go number one
like I just lost everything what
happened there
Oh mine mine ha ha ha ha no no ok so now
we have two more skills
I can stop I'm going to guess what that
one does I'm not going to try it right
now and then yeah I can probably go
through other people but ah suck a dick
penguin sorry I take this game way too
seriously
I'm killing it I'm killing it a distinct
I was born to play I am disty I am the
one don't wait a ton don't need the gun
to get respect up on their treat get out
of my way get out of my goddamn way die
that's why no mercy Oh another 149 we go
in for number 1 if I did the play game
that's because I'm too good at it I'm
too goddamn do it at it I was born
inside up stop you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
that's ok that's a minor inconvenience
we will get back to the top we can also
play that game that's my snake suck it
hey wait a minute that guy has my skin
well it's not really me use it for
whatever a small setback don't you worry
we are going to number one no matter
what okay so there's items in the game
as well whoa look at that boy oh yeah me
can I get another one of those please
to be honest this is hella tight man I
need to start using my skills I think
that's the problem
oh you just got outplayed well I am so
sorry the hell did you just do oh no
y'all gets unplayed what's up when I
respect Corman no oh you try to do it
fast make on me the greatest message
they're gonna promise
whoo oh [ __ ] look at that dog what the
hell in it Oh
what was that boy oh no you got trapped
no no he got Fred someone do something
no no please oh it's a tragedy oh no he
got crap oh no
oh no you can't do that you can't do
that boss
no now why they hit stop ha ha doctor
yes [ __ ] it's so desperate oh my god
it's a goddamn some goddamn warfare out
there oh my god I am now on xbox sick
hi guys would you guys like to get eat
then triple feeding that's right you
live inside me now you live inside me
oh you think you're gonna live
alright will cute oh let's go yeah brah
triple what happened here oh no I let
one escape
I'll wait they all died oh no Jun do not
Jun do judo just end your life please
ain't got time for it Jun de there's no
way out
judo just stopped Jindo please Jindo
come on man you're being a super lame
right now Jindo now Joe you know
[Music]
the way out
and now you know
not beautiful dudu just ng life
the vegetation
thanks Rick
you know you know come on
being a super lame right now even though
[Music]
ah King more like suck my ass got'em
goddamn this is intense
oh my god yes this is awesome
yeah more power unlimited bow oh no you
got friends no no is that rare I am the
one dangerous dangerous well I use the
ability I use the ability that are the
mega nice kick
you can hit stop and you will stop
immediately it's the youthful ability oh
my god everyone is dying everyone died
ha ha ha ha ha ha sorry sorry guys these
are all my babies
oh they keep coming how was that what
are they doing
oh no they keep dying on me what are
they doing seventeen baby
you just got friends in the pootie plant
that's right boy it means it means that
what did you go to Pisa and suck my feet
oh yeah boy yeah
[Music]
Oh No buddy you did get what what how
yes give me all these rewards okay
all right I'm gonna have to change in to
my PewDiePie skin boy you too oh my god
out laid out blade mother out out played
you've all been outplayed sons of becak
outplayed I am a snake I am a snake I am
a goddamn snake I am a snake I am oh god
I'm getting trapped I'm getting crap I'm
getting truck oh no oh no you made an
oopsie Oh Oh then your plea they'd not
talk don't kill me I like they owe
[Music]
[Music]
I have returned there is only one hope
for me let to ever become number one
help me Pierce help me get to number one
that's right everyone in this game you
can buy artifacts choose an artifact to
buy I will buy the radioactive thing
which does so that if they attack me if
I die they can't grow any more
Wow did you know that Piers Morgan Wow
I must kill at least Pierce Morgan for
no reason ever find me oh I see I see
you on the map
hey right hello yeah you could
technically just feed me thank you
right yeah I'll see you
feed me pic please feed me feed me
Pierce
you should oh wow what are you doing is
that's me careful Wow
okay like a golden dragon hey that's
crime here you crazy
[Music]